wir haben ein wenig am Bewertung raten
Format gefallen weil ihr zurecht gesagt
habt die Hälfte der Bewertung ist die
Lieferung und dann ist es quasi
unmöglich die Bewertung richtig zu
erraten wir machen das heute mit einer
anderen liefer-app bestellen drei
verschiedene Burger und ich muss
zuordnen welcher hat welche Bewertung
beim letzten Mal das nicht so gut
geklappt schauen wir mal gemeinsam ob es
heute ein bisschen besser klappen wird
wie immer Eric bestellt und ich muss
erraten wir rufen uns in den Kopf dass
er am besten nichts nehmen was ich kenne
okay wenn ich das so sehe aber ich
rieche Bock darauf wir werden wie gesagt
wieder drei Restaurants raussuchen
Bewertungen haben wir von sehr sehr gut
bis auch schlechter zum Glück schlecht
ist halt immer relativ weit ne weil die
schmeißen glaube ich die Restaurants
raus wenn sie zu schlecht sind aber in
dem Sinne ist so eine Sechs eine sieben
schon schlecht ich schaue jetzt einfach
mal und dann sehen wir was ich
ausgesucht habe kann ich die Augen
aufmachen ja okay okay okay okay ich
dachte ich sehe jetzt schon alles direkt
ja
vor mir vor euch seht ihr die Bewertung
der heutigen Bestellung es sind keine
sternebewertungen wie beim letzten Mal
sondern die App funktioniert halt mit
Bewertung von 0 bis 10 wobei man sagen
muss es gibt eigentlich keine
Restaurants mit zwei drei oder sogar
einem Punkt es fängt so ab 6 7 an also
ich habe noch nichts schlechteres
gesehen bei der App weil die dann halt
die Sachen rausschmeißen und so aber es
wird bestimmt richtig richtig schwierig
heute weil es eigentlich auch eher
Premium Essen dort gibt springt doch mal
rüber ja schau dir mal an wie die
heutigen Bewertungen Auspacken werden
schauen wir mal wir haben
7,88,8 und
9,0,2 zwischen den beiden ja okay wie
soll ich denn diesen Unterschied jemals
merken es geht ja auch ein bisschen um
Spaß ja also klar aber das war so das
untere Ende schon von dem was möglich
war ne es gibt nur gute Burger in Köln
scheinbar ja sehr gut boah einmal Probst
und Eric für die Kalligraphie Skills es
sieht richtig gut aus und ich bin
gespannt wie der erste Burger aussehen
wird sind alle schon da deshalb möge der
erste Burger kommen okay der erste
Burger kommt und wow der sieht super aus
also Brioche bun mit weißem und
schwarzen Sesam Cheddar Käse mir läuft
direkt das Wasser ich habe richtig ich
habe richtig Appetit aber wir können den
so richtig schön auseinanderbauen und zu
checken wie der aufgebaut ist das Patty
sieht sehr durch aus so das ist per See
erstmal nichts schlechtes ist allerdings
kein Smash Patty oder nicht so hart
gesmasht ja oder nicht so hartgemischt
das stimmt da drunter haben wir ein
bisschen so ein Blattsalat Mix wir haben
ein Zwiebelringe Tomate und die Soße
sieht aus wie so ein klassischer Ketchup
Mayo Gurkenstückchen Gemisch aus das
Bahn gefällt mir aber sehr sehr gut also
super fluffig darf ich so ein
mittelschnitt machen ich finde ja ich
darf das
ich mach das also ich nehme das hier
nicht auf die leichte Schulter beim
letzten Mal mit der Pizza hat es mich
schon ein bisschen gekränkt dass das
nicht so richtig gut funktioniert hat
also das dann ist wirklich es ist schon
fast eine zehn aber ja das Patty ist
sehr durchgebraten ich frage mich ob der
dann noch so saftig ist der Burger das
ist für mich die große Frage ich würde
jetzt schon direkt die 9,0 die Top
Bewertung ausschließen aber 9,08,8 ist
halt wirklich so nah beieinander kann
man eigentlich schon fast gar nicht mehr
so viel sagen aber das ist also ich
würde es trotzdem schon als
premium-burger bezeichnen keine Frage
okay das Band ja Kartoffel Mehl mäßig
oder ja Kartoffelmehl auf jeden Fall
Butter aber ich frage mich auch woher
diese gelbe Farbe kommt vielleicht so so
same oder so auch so Maismehl probiere
doch ich probiere einfach ja riecht
ultra lecker los geht's
klingt saftig eigentlich Mund ist auch
auf dich das liegt aber so vor allem an
Soße und Gemüse wobei kann man das
Fleisch ja es ist schon saftig das
könnte aber saftiger sein ich verstehe
was der Burger auch nicht macht ist so
verschmilzt so zu einem zu werden
deshalb meine erste Tendenz eigentlich
die 8,8 ist also weil er einfach
trotzdem zu gut ist er ist so zu gut um
unten zu stehen wie ist denn das Patty
an sich denkst du das war ein frisch
gewoltes denkst du das war ein
tiefgefrorenes frisches Patty sieht man
auch gut so am Rand und so das ist nicht
so industriell geformt oder so ich
glaube das ist schon frisch gebeugt ein
bisschen tot gegrillt vielleicht aber
trotzdem sehr sehr gut was für ein Salat
ist das Rucola ich habe ein klassischen
Cheeseburger bestellt ne bei allen drei
interessant
das war einfach so Spinat wahrscheinlich
oder so okay ich gehe mit einer 8,8 rein
zu bereit für den zweiten Burger ich bin
bereit ich bin aufgeregt ich habe immer
noch krassen Hunger deshalb bring it on
wow
das wird schwer heute so viel kann man
auf jeden Fall sagen guck mal das bannen
sieht noch mehr so homemade aus das
sieht so aus als hätten ja so frisch mit
Butter beschmiert nach dem Backen im
Ofen so das sieht richtig gut aus der
Burger sieht auch spitze aus also auch
selbst geformtes Patty auch wieder sowas
wie Cheddar als Käse oder Käse wieder so
verlaufen ist krank oder boah man sieht
das hat kurz gestanden aber wirklich nur
ganz kurz der Käse ist aber ein bisschen
fest irritiert mich gerade das bannen
ist voll jetzt habe ich doch so große
Worte schon über das andere Band
verloren aber das ist auch spitze hier
ist ein bisschen Widerstand beim
Schneiden und das Messer ist sehr scharf
aber hier wird Cheeseburger ernst
genommen Alter was Cheeseburger ist
jetzt Cheeseburger okay das ist wirklich
nur so Fleisch von Käse ja also das ist
oh man sieht sogar die einzelnen layers
der Käse ist nicht perfekt geschmolzen
dass man schon mal bemerken kann man
sieht wenn man genau dort 123 Scheiben
Cheddar Käse und sonst ist gar nichts
drauf ist das gut oder ist das schlecht
frage ich mich gerade das ist auch eine
Frage die ich mir gerade Stelle so
Garstufe identisch also auch tot was
sagst du zum Patty an sich man das
müsste ich ja von unten gut lösen ja das
Patty ist schon auch sehr
durchgegrillt sieht aber auch wieder aus
als sei es nicht unbedingt Tiefkühl ich
bin hier gerade mit Argusaugen am
Stapler hier sind so diese gelier peace
ist drin ja komm wir drücken mal wir
machen mal den juice Test
der Juice ist schon noch da ne muss man
sagen also ein bisschen zumindest nicht
lang schnacken Kopf in Nacken immer
sag ich ja immer
das klingt nicht so gut deutlich so mehr
kauarbeit gefragt einfach keine runde
Sache so dieses so dass das das ist
nicht so ein also wer war ja schon so
mit einzubestandteil und das hier ist so
du schmeckst Käse du schmeckst fertigen
schmeckst Brot du hast keine keinen so
nicht diese geile vollmundige Erfahrung
der ist einfach keine geile Kreation bin
jetzt im Vergleich
ja und der ist wirklich so also der ist
hart draußen so ja ich mach kurzen
Prozess das ist für mich die 7,8 das
muss sehr schlechteste Burger des Tages
sein das Auge ist mit so aber das Auge
kann auch nicht über alles
hinwegtäuschen wenn man das Auge außer
Acht lässt dann geht da nicht so viel
bei dem Burger ich hoffe dass jetzt der
dritte Burger mich nicht komplett aus
dem Konzept bringt weil wenn der jetzt
mir weniger schmeckt als die anderen
dann bin ich wieder komplett verwirrt
7,8 eine letzte Bewertung haben wir noch
übrig die Top Bewertung 9,0 das sind
meine beiden bisherigen Kandidaten ich
habe eigentlich ein gutes Gefühl heute
aber wir gucken mal ob sich das jetzt
ändert
hör mal big Papa Dani ist ein Oschi sage
ich mal also auch wieder hier Brioche
spannen jedes Panzer super aus also das
war auf jeden Fall schon heute Bang
Champions League so ein Pixar lässt das
Ganze immer noch mal so ein bisschen
krasser aussehen und so die Bauhöhe ist
auch eine andere als bei den anderen
Burgern phänomenal schon fast phänomenal
also super weit von unten das erste mal
so ganz normaler Salat kein
angetoastetes Bann und keine Soße und
keine Soße oben drauf du hast recht
schon das ist schon ein bisschen
eigenartig auch hier wieder Cheddar Käse
also wir haben heute schon echt so uns
in einer relativ eng definierten Sphäre
bewegt der mittelschnitt gibt uns
hoffentlich mehr Klarheit
wir sehen auf jeden Fall
glücklicherweise mangelt es doch nicht
an Soße die ist einfach nur nicht oben
am Band wir haben hier sowas wie so eine
ja so ein klassische Burger Soße so ein
gelbliches etwas unten haben wir Mario
wir haben wie es aussieht in jede Menge
juice außer im Patty also muss trotzdem
sagen an die Kölner Burger Spots also
meinetwegen könnte ja auch ein bisschen
weniger durch beraten das sind alles
Läden die ich nicht kenne zumindest
erkenne ich keinen der Burger deshalb
kann ich auch nicht daraus Rückschlüsse
ziehen auf die mögliche Bewertung da
habe ich ja schon mal Glück gehabt dass
ich diesmal keinen ausgewählt habe wenn
du kannst es ähm wusstest du ja auch
noch Syria aber ich habe es versucht
zumindest unkenntlich zu machen und
diesmal habe ich ganz akribisch drauf
geachtet sehr gut dann lass diesmal auch
die Adresse drauf also wir drücken das
ein bisschen zusammen und unser Burger
dann schmilzt direkt auf die Wunschgröße
das ist geil das ist geil das das bleibt
auch so sticky macht auch Spaß ich
erwarte mir viel von diesem Biss also
auch mein Kopf sagt mir automatisch dass
wir es nur noch 9, sondern das muss der
Beste sein aber probieren wir der
Geschmack wirds verraten
der schmeckt automatisch so am
frischsten also am meisten so dieses
frische Gefühl im Mund das viel so Salat
Gurke Tomaten Zwiebel drauf ne was das
auch glaube ich dann mit ihm macht aber
ist ja Käse drauf Käse ist auch so ich
bin auf jeden Fall happy bei eher nicht
schlechter ist für mich als die Burger
die davor da waren weil sonst hätte ich
wieder gar nichts verstanden die Soße ne
diese gelbe Sandwich Burger Soße wie
schmeckt so gekauft was für mich
zumindest persönlich direkt so einen
Eindruck vermittelt sondern man denkt
direkt das kann eigentlich nicht der
allerbeste sein aber wenn sie gekauft
schmeckt kannst du sie auch zuordnen zu
einer bekannten Soße oder ich kenne
keinen Namen für die Soße aber diese
gelbliche Soße die so ein bisschen
stückig ist die heißt so hot dog Soße
genau
wir haben hier auf jeden Fall einen
Burger der sich Mühe gegeben hat der
Burger hier hat sich gar keine Mühe
gegeben wir haben gesagt wir haben
gehört Cheeseburger okay machen wir
entschieden und fertig die anderen
beiden habe ich Gedanken gemacht die
anderen beiden haben sich Gedanken
gemacht so wir haben einen super schönes
Bahn super fluffy Sesam ein bisschen
platzsalat hier das mörderband super
fluffig schöne Soßen aber eben eine
gekaufte und ich muss einfach sagen von
meiner Erfahrung her auch muss ich
vielleicht den Wechsel noch machen
inwiefern ich esse erstmal auf und dann
verrate ich euch gleich wie meine finale
Entscheidung aussieht ich sag so viel
man hätte sich denken können 9,08,8 es
ist kein leichtes heute nur der hier ist
es auf jeden Fall nicht
ich bin an diesem Zeitpunkt wirklich
immer aufgeregt aber wirklich so ernst
aufgeregt weil irgendwie will ich das
immer richtig haben wir können ja
erstmal prüfen ist das hier richtig lege
ich mit 7,8 Punkten für diesen
Cheeseburger richtig oder das ist ein
Cheeseburger vom Hard Rock Café Köln
okay ja das klingt schon mal nicht
verkehrt das Hard Rock Café in Köln hat
eine Bewertung von 8,8 nein schon wieder
schon wieder die anderen Burger waren so
super
das heißt ich habe hoffentlich
wenigstens einen von beiden hier richtig
ja der mittlere Burger ist von banks
Burger und nicht mit a sowie bang bang
wo wird Billy cheese Steak gegessen
haben sondern mit E banks Burger okay
mit einer Bewertung von 7,8 krass okay
okay okay das darauf kann ich schließen
dass der hier zumindest richtig ist
darüber bin ich sehr froh aber sorry
side by side von den beiden Bürgern
also das ist für mich auch wieder keine
Diskussion ich finde es aber umso
interessanter weil das ist ja im Laden
der nur Burger macht so hier laufen so
ein bisschen so fremdbewertungen mit
rein vielleicht macht super Caesar Salad
und alle Leute lieben den und bestellen
nur den und geben dann immer zehn Punkte
aber das sind so die Sachen die ich so
ein bisschen probieren muss zu reverse
engineieren ich muss probieren so
dahinter zu kommen es ist mir heute
wieder nicht so ganz gut gelungen lass
uns doch den letzten Laden nennen und
zwar ist das Cheeseburger Eddie mit
einer Bewertung von 9,0 sogar auf Platz
1 bei wollt bester Burger dann besser
also zu dem Zeitpunkt wo wir geschaut
haben nach der Sortierung okay krass
weil ich habe noch nie Cheeseburger
Eddie bestellt und ich wollte es schon
immer mal testen aber gut dass es nicht
gemacht aber ich hatte wirklich keine
Ahnung ich glaube das bannen macht ganz
viel bei dem das ist ein kartoffelbang
glaube ich okay sonst wäre es nicht so
gelb kann gut sein es war mal wieder
deutlich schwieriger als gedacht ich
hatte wie immer eigentlich gar keine
Ahnung vielleicht hattet ihr ja mehr
Plan mehr Erfolg und hat besser geraten
als ich schreibe gerne in die Kommentare
mit welcher Speise wir das ganze als
nächstes machen sollen bis dahin macht
es gut und hier
hier ist ein für dich vorgeschlagenes
Video deshalb gerne einfach draufklicken
und den Kanal abonnieren wenn ihr das
Video gefallen hat damit würdest du mich
sehr erquicken und die Glocke und die
Glocke auch die abonnieren die Glocke
deabonnieren und dann noch mal drücken
okay ciao bis zum nächsten Mal